good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're gonna do something
a little different for the next hour
we're gonna try to explain what this
country is fighting with itself about
what are the lines that divide us
it's pretty obviously not the old
partisan divide that the rest of us grew
up with republican versus democrat you
figured that out now you look over the
democratic side you see rashida talib
you're pretty certain she's not
on your side obviously but then the
question is is mitch mcconnell on your
side and the answer as you well know is
no not really
so what divides us what is the dividing
line and it's really simple
the people in charge
are intent on replacing our free
democratic system within a tour
authoritarian system where they don't
convince you of anything they simply
make you do things and they benefit from
that
there are people in this country who are
opposed to that they are
anti-authoritarian and if you look at
who we book on this show that may
explain why we do it you may have
noticed we have a lot of former lefties
on the show glenn greenwald is the most
obvious alex berenson as well and many
others
now we probably don't agree with these
people on a lot of things are we on the
same side of an abortion we've never
asked
but one thing we know for certain is
that they are totally opposed to
authoritarianism so that really is the
divide people are for an authoritarian
america and those who are for a free
america it's that simple and once you
start to understand politics through
that lens
you figure out what's really going on
by the way looking at polls is an
unusually bad way to understand what's
happening in american politics polls are
often wrong and when they are wrong
they're almost always wrong in the same
direction the last presidential election
made that very clear the polling outfit
quinny quinnipiac for example which was
attached to some kind of college in
connecticut predicted that joe biden
would win the popular vote by 11 points
it also predicted that mitch mcconnell
was in tough shape in kentucky
pollsters even convinced a lot of
democratic party donors that they had a
real shot of winning the state of texas
in retrospect it's clear all of this was
partisan fantasy and it had a purpose it
was all designed to make a mentally
decaying senator from delaware look like
teddy roosevelt riding a massive wave of
popular support
of course that was a lie
so once you understand that once you
recognize what these polls are actually
designed to do
they're designed to put democratic party
leaders in the best possible light
it is worth noting when the polls move
in the opposite direction when they
start to reflect badly on the democratic
party that's been happening over the
past several weeks according again to
quinnipiac
a reliably left-wing pollster joe
biden's national approval rating is now
38 percent
60 percent of independents disapprove of
what joe biden is doing as president
a new ap poll noted that just 34 percent
of americans are pleased with the
direction of the country that's called
the right track wrong track poll and for
the party in power it is very bad news
this means that the very same people who
just last year lied to you to your face
about how popular joe biden was are now
admitting that he is actually the least
popular president in modern political
history
why are they telling you this all of a
sudden
why are these reliably democratic
pollsters telling democratic voters that
their president is unpopular
maybe because they have no choice maybe
there are other reasons we're not sure
what is absolutely clear is that
according to a new poll from pew
democratic party voters understand what
this means and what it means is
in a free and fair democratic system
they can't win
if we allocate power based on who's the
most popular with the public and that's
the basic premise of democracy
the democratic party is in very tough
shape
and they know that
and that may be why according to polls
democrats now overwhelmingly want the
government to make their political
opponents shut up
more than three quarters of democratic
party voters want the tech companies to
quote restrict false information online
even if it limits freedom of information
think about that for a second more than
60 percent of democratic voters want the
federal government to quote control that
flow of information over the internet
so all of that contravenes the first
amendment to the bill of rights which is
the very core of our system of
government and of our culture it's what
makes america great and now the
overwhelming majority of democratic
voters are against it
so that's authoritarianism there's no
other word for it and it's ironic
considering for four years prominent
democrats told us we were living through
a fascist system donald trump was a
fascist
but of course they were describing their
own attitudes
so we're going to spend the next hour
looking at the rise of authoritarian
impulses on the left and try to figure
out where those came from and where
they're going
now none of this is brand new you'll
recall that democratic party politicians
have been pushing for censorship for a
long time certainly since trump won in
2016. they blamed that victory on
facebook
here's ed markey in last october for
example calling for more censorship
the issue is not that the companies
before us today are taking too many
posts down
the issue is that they're leaving too
many dangerous posts up
in fact they're amplifying harmful
content so that it spreads like wildfire
and tortures our democracy
oh they're not censoring enough because
these posts according to ed markey who
will literally say anything you should
know
are quote dangerous
but marquee never explained what was
dangerous about them but you got the
message
they all did a few weeks after marquis
said that big tech effectively removed
the elected president of the united
states from the internet they silenced
him completely and virtually nobody said
anything about it
so it didn't stop it merely accelerated
now democrats and their allies in the
news media have decided to drop all
pretense
jonathan chait writes for new york
magazine he's considered smart on the
left one of the weirdest people
practicing journalism today he just
published a deeply revealing piece in
new york magazine here's the headline
from it and we're quoting
anybody fighting joe biden is helping
trump's next coup
all republican politics is now
functionally authoritarian
all right
because republicans are calling for
censorship
so that's how the democratic party is
responding to the collapsing poll
numbers of their president
they're accusing the other side of
authoritarianism while practicing it
themselves
right
so you'll recall that joe biden voters
destroyed statues and destroyed our
country's biggest cities for more than a
year and the police did nothing about it
and our media class applauded
and yet because justice is no longer
meted out equally if someone dares to
dishonor the legacy of saint george
floyd the new york police department's
special hate crimes division springs
into action here's an actual quote by
the way
from this week
on october 3rd 2021 at approximately 10
15 a.m in union square park a person on
a skateboard threw gray paint on the
face and base of a statue of george
floyd
that's the nypd bulletin information
contact us exclamation point
so that's not really hypocrisy anymore
it's hierarchy what they're telling you
is that crimes against their ideas are
the only crimes that matter
well that attitude has no popular
support in this country so you can only
enforce it by force using surveillance
to root out people who've got the wrong
ideas and that's exactly the basis on
which the buy administration is
proceeding that's why the administration
has now given itself the authority to
monitor everything that happens for
example in your private bank account
an effort
that i know you're a proponent of for
the irs to collect more uh information
um and and and more tax dollars but more
information about taxpayers bank
accounts including annual cash flows and
i was curious whether you think the irs
has the the wherewithal to actually do
that
well of course they do
and a simple way for the irs to get a
sense of where that might be is just a
few pieces of information about
individuals bank accounts
did you see that the most interesting
part of that exchange was not the
treasury secretary she's embraced
authoritarianism full-blown it's the
creepy little shill from cnbc and the
question is not does the irs have the
right to snoop into your bank account
with no evidence you've done anything
wrong his question is do they have the
wherewithal do they have the manpower
can they actually pull it off
to what she says of course we're the
government we can do anything
so after january 6 this show reported
that bank of america quote proactively
rooted through customers private
financial informations to find
individuals who quote met thresholds of
interest they spied on their own
customers and then like the good east
germans they are they pass those names
to the fbi without telling anybody
involved
the democratic party approves of this
and they want to make certain this kind
of invasion of privacy is permanent it's
codified
and of course they want to control your
children too the center of your life
they'll destroy anyone who tries to
stand in the way of this
bradley keys for example we could give
you a million here's just one
keys was a track and field coach at
pembroke academy he was fired because he
didn't think it was good for his
athletes to have to wear masks as they
were playing tennis watch
my goal is to get these mandates removed
and it's not just track and field it's
tennis it's baseball it's every outdoor
sport mask will be where
mass will be worn all times practices
and
competitions tennis wonderful example
singles tennis you go watch practices
everyone's wearing masks competitions
they will be wearing masks even though
they're 30 to 60 feet apart on the
courts
so we're going to tell you we've told
you a thousand times before none of this
is science there's not a single study
anywhere in the world that suggests kids
benefit by wearing masks as they play
sports outdoors in fact they are hurt by
it that's both common sense and the
scientific consensus on the question
but the fact is it's happening anyway
and that's the point
they don't feel the need to justify
their decisions with science and in fact
they will punish actual scientists who
object to these unnecessary medical
mandates erin carrity for example is a
physician at the university of
california he's the director of the
medical ethics program at uc irvine not
a small job
he's just announced the university has
quote put me on leave why
for challenging their vaccine mandates
in court
oh
so it's not a question of whether
vaccine mandates help or hurt or good
for public health
it's about power and anyone who
challenges it is crushed
the weak are hurt the most profoundly as
always
here's the story we'll be telling you a
lot more about it in coming weeks about
a woman in colorado who is facing death
she's got stage five renal failure she's
just been denied a kidney transplant now
she has a donor a willing donor who has
a kidney for her everything is ready to
go
but according to the health system there
the woman and her donor have not taken
the kovid shot
the donor explained that her vaccination
status quote does not affect any other
patient on the transplant list how can i
sit here the donor asked and allow them
to murder my friend when i've got a
perfectly good kidney and i could save
her life that's a great question
no one in the bible administration is
bothered to answer it or even think
about it
instead they're forcing anyone who
raises these questions to be quiet
that's not a democratic system that's an
authoritarian system hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else